j'ai commise décision difficile très
difficile pour moi uniquement parce que
j'ai considéré que vous intéresser
la rumeur était persistante ces derniers
jours c'est désormais officiel alain jaj
quitte son poste de maire de la verrière
c'était lors du conseil municipal
mercredi soir qu'il a choisi de
l'annoncé non sans émotion des raisons
de santé l'ont poussé à ces résultats
comme toujours dans ce moment là on
espère que les choses vont s'améliorer
s'arranger c'est pas tout à fait le kg
la situation de santé encore besoin
d'attention de soins est en tout cas
incompatible avec
le rythme de vie qu'imposent les
fonctions de maire dans une petite
commune faut être extrêmement présent il
faut être à l'écouté et puis moi je ne
sais pas faire autrement que ça c'est en
2012 après le départ de pierre c'est
lincourt élu depuis 29 ans qu'alain ajaj
devient mère il s'impose rapidement dans
ce rôle
en 2014 il obtient près de 60% des
suffrages lors de l'élection municipale
déjà affaibli en raison de sa santé il
prend l'année suivante plusieurs mois de
repos mais dès son retour il s'engage
sur d'importants dossiers rénovation du
quartier du bois de l'étang et
développement de celui des bécanes je
n'avais pas vocation à être mère 36
mandat c'est pas ma conception
je pense que il faut laisser la place
aux jeunes le moment venu j'aurais
évidemment apprécié de boire finir ce
mandat
notant que c'est un mandat c'est
déterminant que me suis impliqué engagé
dans beaucoup de projets pour l'avenir
ah je les verrai autrement alain ajaj
restera conseiller municipal nelly duthu
devrait lui succéder le 14 avril
prochain lors du nouveau scrutin interne
aux élus les habitants ne devront pas
retourner aux urnes
sa mère qui a qui s'est beaucoup battu
pour sa ville qui est très très présent
qui a travaillé
sans compter faut quand même le dire est
dans l'intérêt de sa population parmi
les réactions politiques celle de son
homologue des républicains à elle en
cours via twitter ou encore celle de la
responsable socialiste du département et
lui attraper qui siège à ses côtés à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines chez nos politiques avec qui
j'ai pris plaisir à travailler qu'un
homme à la fois particulièrement
brillant intelligent et en même temps
événement vraiment proche des gens donc
il y avait un travail qui était très
très utile et très agréable avec lui il
a une vision il sait ce qu'il veut faire
pas toujours le cas de tous les hommes
politiques faut bien reconnaître là
beaucoup d'hommes politiques sont des
gestionnaires mais c'est pas un
gestionnaire simplement est quelqu'un
qui avait une vision sur qu'est ce qu'il
voulait pour son territoire pour les
habitants son territoire tous les
habitants de la verrière viennent de
recevoir dans leur boîte aux lettres un
courrier les informant de ce départ